welcome my lord to the new world before
a slice our friend home of the high airs
at its center at the very Isle of the
Dead the great vortex surges and swirls
forged by the High Elves in ages past to
siphon the wings of magic and defeat the
chaos invasion threatened to engulf the
world as the fork-tongued comet of so
tech made its recent passage across the
heavens he preached the great warding
making it dangerously unstable there are
those who would unbind the vortex and
exploit its wild energies still others
seek to heal the cyclone and preserve
the order each race must perform a
series of arcane rituals both to decide
the fate of the vortex and prevent the
other races from achieving victory
let us take a closer look at the High
Elves led by Prince Tyrion they are a
proud arrogant and highly developed
people combining peerless martial
prowess
with an uncommon grasp of the magical
arts the High Elves are in love with
politics and the most successful elven
leaders use their influence to court the
most powerful generals and meddle in the
affairs of other lesser races
[Music]
the High Elves are also master printers
and exploit their contacts to gain
valuable intelligence of the affairs of
their trading partners
to the north of Alton live asked near
unassailable fortress gates guarding the
outer reaches of the elven homelands it
would take a formidable force indeed to
breach these ramparts and now the elves
have enacted a ritual this puts them one
step closer to stabilizing the vortex
and achieving their ultimate victory
with continents separated by mighty
oceans your forces may have to embark on
perilous journeys to reach foreign soil
risking encounters with deadly storms
even skirting the coastlines and pose a
threat as treacherous reefs and shallows
take their toll on the drafts of your
transport ships
here in lust RIA certain races of the
old world have gained footholds will you
put their outpost to the sword or make
allies of these adventurers securing
their loyalty for the challenges to come
across the landscape lie the ruins of
ancient cities you may choose to erect
new settlements in their place or
instead delve them for hidden riches and
lost magical artifacts dangers may lurk
in the depths however
be ever watchful for rogue armies roamed
these lands composed of warriors from
many races they lay aside their former
animosities and band together in the
pursuit of riches and power
not all legendary Lords campaign within
their homelands the High Elf Archmage
Tech list begins here on the turtle
Isles
deep in lizard man country he faces are
wholly different set of challenges from
his brother Tyrion in health well lost
Ria's jungles are the domain of illicit
men their fearsome saurian beasts the
slan mage priests rule over this place
directing the lizard men according to
the great plan decreed by the old ones
they who seek to preserve the vortex and
prevent calamity
the chia Mantic web ancient lines of
power connecting the great temple cities
lies in disarray
should the lizard-men revitalize these
strands their efforts to enact the great
plan will be much convulsed and here we
see Nord maasdam
mightiest of the living slab he and his
army have adopted the astrum insistence
granting them unmatched insight into
their surroundings finally let us join
the legendary Soros warrior Croc guard
his Lizard Men cohorts as they prepare
to do battle with a high elf force at
the ancient portal of the Fallen gates